prince Andrew the Duke of York issued a  statement in tribute to his mother  addressed to Mummy mother your majesty  three in one he said your majesty it has  been an honor and privilege to serve you  mother of the nation your devotion and  personal service to our nation is unique  and singular your people show their love  and respect in so many different ways  and I know you are looking on honoring  their respect mummy your love for a son  your compassion your care your  confidence I will treasure forever I  have found your knowledge and wisdom  infinite with no boundary or containment  I will miss your insights advice and  humor as our book of experiences closes  another opens and I will forever hold  you close to my heart with my deepest  love and gratitude and I will tread  gladly into the next with you as my  guide God Save the King